we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 830
4750 our next callers from the 904 area
code let's start with your name and
where you're calling from hey my name is
Matt I'm calling from Orlando Florida
awesome what's on your mind map arm so
decent portion of climate scientists are
funded whether through academia or
through business interests arm do
mainstream climate scientists have a
motive to underreport what is going on
with the climate do Main Street so by
mainstream do you mean the ones funded
by corporations and educational
institutions I wanna make sure I have
the question roll mainstream yeah
mainstream is in like those kind of
scientists but mainstream also is in
like ones that my work in universities
or in sort of an academic capacity well
it you know I think there's no blanket
answer to that so big picture we have
overwhelmingly climate scientists
believe that human activities on earth
are impacting the climate Donald Trump
for example has said that he believes
human affected climate change is a hoax
created by the Chinese for the purposes
of bolstering a Japanese manufacturer
Chinese manufacturing rather so there's
there's two different views one of them
is the overwhelming consensus of science
if you were to look at some individual
studies at universities for example you
can find individual university studies
that are underwritten by corporations
that have a vested interest in
continuing to exploit the fossil fuels
and natural resources of the planet so
you could make the argument that there
might be a conflict there and that the
professor's uh and and scientists doing
the investigation would have sort of a
financial motive for underreporting the
severity of climate change however most
scientists I've spoken to it
universities have been pretty clear that
even in cases where they know that their
their work is partially underwritten by
up for example fossil fuel company or
one of these oil lobbies or it or or
industry groups that really it's pretty
clearly separated what they are doing
from the
at one of these organizations may be
funding them so I've not spoken to too
many scientists who truly feel that the
academic level they have any kind of
incentive to underreport the severity of
of climate science but of course you
know we've known that for decades
companies including Exxon boat mobile
whose CEO is going to be our incoming
secretary of state which is incredibly
disturbing they've known for a very long
time about the connection between human
activities on earth and the impact on
the climate and they funded uh what's
called sort of doubt doubt studies which
cast doubt on to the source of some of
this climate change so it exists but by
and large I don't know that I would
assume that that in academia you're
seeing an under-representation of it
what what do you think okay I'm I mean
yeah that makes a lot of sense I would
obviously say that media is under
reporting it a lot of mainstream media
yawn but I mean I've just seen so many
studies that have displayed the severity
and I just don't see you talked about
enough yeah and you know what corporate
media also does is they do the false
balance thing which is in order to
perceived as fair they'll say well we'll
give will bring on two people to talk
about this one that believes what the
ninety-eight percent of climate
scientists say one that believes what
the two percent say but we'll pretend
like there's really a 50-50 debate here
and that's a corporate media tactic
that's really really a destructive thank
you so much for the call I really really
appreciate it